in all of the double integrals we've
done so far the boundaries on x and y
were fixed now we'll see what happens
when the boundaries on x and y
are variable
so let's say i have the same surface and
i'm just going to i'm not going to draw
it the way it looks i'll just kind of
draw it figuratively but the problem
we're actually going to do
is z and this is the exact same one
we've been doing all along but the point
of here isn't to show you how to
integrate the point of here is to show
you how to visualize and think about
these problems and frankly in double
integral problems the hardest part is
figuring out the boundaries once you do
that the integration is pretty
straightforward it's really not any
harder than single variable integration
so let's say that's our surface z is
equal to xy squared and let me draw
the axes again
so that's my
x-axis
that's my z-axis
that's my y-axis
x
y and z
and you saw what this graph looked like
several videos ago i took out the whole
grapher and we rotated and things
i'm not going to draw the graph the way
it looks i'm just going to
draw it fairly abstractly as just an
abstract surface because the point here
is really to figure out the boundaries
of integration
so before i actually even draw the
surface i'm going to draw the boundary
so every every the first time we did
this problem we said okay x goes from 0
to 2 y goes from 0 to 1 and then we
figured out the volume above that
bounded domain
now let's do something else let's figure
out let's say that x goes from
0 to 1.
so x goes from 0 to 1.
and let's say
that the domain the the
volume that we want to
figure out
under the surface
it's not from
a fixed y to an upper bound y
although it kind well i'll show you it's
actually a curve so this is this is all
on the x y plane everything i'm drawing
here and this curve
is we could view it two ways we could
say y is a function of x y is equal to x
squared or we could write x is equal to
square root of y we don't have to write
plus or minus or anything like that
because we're in the first quadrant
so this is the area above which we want
to figure out the volume
let me yeah it doesn't hurt to color it
in
just so we can
really
hone in on what we care about so that's
the area above which we want to figure
out the volume or kind of you could kind
of say that's our bounded domain
and so x goes from 0 to 1 and then this
point is going to be what that's that
point's going to be 1 comma 1 right
1 is equal to 1 squared 1 is equal to
square root of 1. so this point is y is
equal to 1.
all right that's y is equal to 1. and
then i'm not going to draw this surface
exactly i'm just trying to give you a
sense of what the volume of the figure
we're trying to calculate is so the top
of
if this is just some arbitrary surface
let me do it in a different color
so this is
the top
this let's see this is this line is
going vertical in the z direction
right actually i could draw it like this
like it's a curve
and then this curve back here is going
to be like a wall
right
that's going to be like a wall
and maybe i'll paint this side of the
wall just so that you can
see what it kind of looks like
trying my best
i think you get an idea let me make it a
little darker this is actually more of
an exercise in art than in
than in math in many ways
you get the idea and then the boundary
here is like this
and this top isn't flat you know it
could be a curved surface
i do it a little like that but it's a
curved surface and we know in the
example we're about to do that this
surface right here z is equal to x
squared so we want to figure out the
volume
under this
so how do we do it well let's think
about it
we could actually use the intuition that
i just gave you
we're essentially just going to take
a d a right which is a little small
square down here
right and that little area that's the
same thing as
a dx let me use a darker color
as a dx
times a d y and then we just have to
multiply it times f of x y or which is
this
for each area and then sum them all up
and then we could take a sum in the x
direction first or the y direction first
now before doing that just to make sure
you that you have the intuition because
the boundaries are the hard part let me
just draw our x y plane so let me rotate
up like that
i'm just going to draw our x y plane
because that's what matters
because the hard part here is just
figuring out our bounds of integration
so the curve is just y is equal to x
squared so it looks something like that
y is equal to x squared this is the
point y is equal to 1. this is y axis
this is the x-axis
this is the point
x is equal to 1.
there you go that's not an x that's a 1.
this is the x-axis anyway so we want to
figure out how do we sum up these d this
dx times d y or this d a
along this domain
along this domain so let's draw it let's
visually draw it and it doesn't hurt to
do this when you actually have to do the
problem because this frankly is the hard
part a lot of calculus teachers will
just have you set up the integral and
then say okay well the rest is easy or
the rest is calc one
okay so this area
this area here is the same thing as this
area here
so its base is dx and its height is d y
right and then we're gonna and then you
can imagine that we're looking at this
thing from above so the surface is up
here someplace and we're looking
straight down on it and so this is just
this area
right so let's say we wanted to take the
integral with respect to x first so we
want to sum up
we want to sum up
the so if we want the volume above this
column first of all is this area times d
x d y right so let's write the volume
above that column it's going to be
the value of the function right the
height
at that point
which is x y squared so it's going to be
x y squared
times dx dy
dx dy
that this expression gives us the volume
above this area or this column right
here and let's say we want to sum in the
x direction first so we want to sum that
dx
someone here some here etcetera etcetera
right so we're going to sum in the x
direction so my question to you is what
is our lower bound of integration
what is our lower bound of integration
well for any we're kind of holding our y
constant right and so if we go to the
left if we go lower and lower x's we
kind of bump into the curve here
right so the lower bound of integration
is actually the curve
and what is this curve if we were to
write x as a function of y right this
curve is y is equal to x squared or x is
equal to square root of y
so if we're integrating with respect to
x for any for a fixed y right here right
where we're integrating in the
horizontal direction first our lower
bound is x is equal to the square root
of y
x is equal to the square root of y
that's interesting i think this is the
first time you've probably seen a
variable bound integral but it makes
sense because for this row that we're
adding up right here the upper bound is
easy the upper bound is x is equal to
one
the upper bound is x is equal to one
but the lower bound is x is equal to the
square root of y right because as you go
back like oh i bump into the curve and
what's the curve well the curve is x is
equal to square root of y because we
don't know which y we picked
fair enough so once we figured out the
volume so that'll give us the volume
above this
rectangle right here and then we want to
add up the dys right
and remember there's a whole volume
above what i'm drawing right here right
i'm just drawing this part in the x y
plane
right so now so what we've done just now
this expression as it's written right
now figures out
the volume above
that rectangle
now if we want to figure out the entire
volume of the of the solid we integrate
along the y axis or we add up all the d
y's right this was a d y right here not
a dx my d x's and d y's look too similar
so now what is the lower bound
what is the lower bound on the y axis if
i'm summing up these rectangles
well the lower bound is y is equal to
zero
right so we're going to go from y is
equal to zero
to what what is the upper bound to y is
equal to one
and there you have it let me rewrite
that integral
so the double integral is going to be
from
x is equal to square root of y
to x is equal to 1
x
y squared dx
d y
and then the y bounds y goes from zero
to y
to one
i've just realized i've run out of time
in the next video we'll evaluate this
and then we'll do it in the other order
see you soon